this neighborhood is known as little
haiti
it lies in santo domingo the capital of
the dominican republic
on the eastern half of the island of
hispaniola about half a million people
from haiti on the western side live here
but since the pandemic they have fewer
jobs especially in construction and
farming
many lack residency permits or access to
employment services and health care
and now the dominican government says it
will build a border wall to keep
migrants from haiti out
in just two years we want to put an end
to the serious problems of illegal
immigration
drug trafficking and the movement of
stolen vehicles and achieve the
protection of our territorial integrity
while some people from haiti who've lost
their jobs now sell whatever they can
on the street tens of thousands have
returned home
the dominican republic is one of the
fastest growing economies in latin
america
while its neighbor is the poorest nation
in the western hemisphere
much of the dominican public supports
the move to increase security along the
border
i think it would be important because it
would control migration from one country
to another
there wouldn't be as many problems as
there could be if the wall is built
and if it's correctly demarcated it's
beneficial for both countries
when border gates opened in dahabon this
past friday hundreds of people from
haiti were able to cross
and sell and exchange goods at a border
market it's one of four
official crossings where many people's
livelihoods depend on informal market
trade
but there are dozens of unofficial
crossings along the 380 kilometer border
critics say the wall won't solve
underlying problems
measures such as increased border
control should ideally be complemented
by measures to promote regular and
orderly migration
the international organization for
migration or iom and other rights groups
are calling for a humanitarian corridor
for those from haiti who are in need
during economic and political crises
there is permanent persecution we really
regret that a government that claims to
be a government of change
is not respecting the dignity and rights
of immigrants in the dominican republic
many in haiti say that despite the
shared ancestry and history on the
island
they've long suffered persecution and
they are concerned the wall will only
create
further division andrew chappelle al
jazeera